le métier de chirurgien dentiste se
féminise on attend d'ici 2022 une
proportion égalitaire entre les hommes
et les femmes
je les bienvenus tout au long de mon
parcours tout d'abord dans ma promotion
il y avait nettement plus de femmes que
d'hommes
ceci montre que la femme aujourd'hui a
le choix de faire des études beaucoup
plus longue pour faire ses études il
faut également réalisé un concours qui
est écrit et anonyme donc totalement
égalitaire entre les sexes
aujourd'hui ma collaboration se passe
avec deux chirurgiens dentistes hommes
je ne ressens aucun complexe
d'infériorité avec les deux et donc
c'est aussi la qualité de ce métier on
peut s'installer en libéral si on le
souhaite et donc ça veut dire être son
propre patron ouvrir son propre cabinet
qu importe le sexe en ce qui concerne la
relation avec le patient celle ci est je
pense un peu plus complexe je me
rappelle d'ailleurs bien dans l'ain
patients au chu de nantes qui
éprouvaient des difficultés à se faire
soigner par une jeune femme
il tenait des propos misogynes tout au
long de la consultation
si ce patient exprimé vraiment se pense
et je pense que beaucoup de patients
aujourd'hui que je traite ont du mal à
faire confiance à une jeune femme
cependant avec la féminisation de la
profession et avec la place grandissante
de la femme dans la société je pense que
cette pensée va être amenée à
disparaître
je ne suis plutôt sûr
[Musique]